land und brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten morgen sicherten markus so
erreiche ich dich ungefähr 80 kilometer
von hier entfernt
unser erster videopodcast eine tatsache
und
die kamera bewegt sich hin und her
müsste das immer so ein bisschen
unheimlich und schaltet ihr mir mein
schicksal zu sein ständig irgendwas vor
kameras oder mit kameras machen zu
müssen dabei mag ich das gar nicht okay
ich habe viele leute zitiert worden dass
ich mal gesagt haben sollte ich stehe
nicht gerne mittelpunkt irgendwo
und tatsächlich ist es richtig ja und es
kann ja beides stimmen ich kenne doch es
kann ja sein dass man sich gar nicht
drauf freut aber wenn man es dann einmal
tut dann macht es nichts aus wenn du
wenn du weißt da ist jetzt schon der auf
genug kommt aus der 11 als deren vortrag
gehalten ist hast du da puls noch bevor
du dann daraus geht also normalerweise
eigentlich fast gar nicht aber man muss
schon sagen also die dlv ist ein
spezieller tempel schon jetzt das dritte
mal da und das ist doch irgendwie wenn
man da raus kommt auch schon ein
erhebendes gefühl würde ich sagen ist
das schon dass er ihn einfach ein toller
raum ich finds hieraus nicht so richtig
hübsch aber innen das ist ein toller
raum ja definitiv und sagt richard
interessant in mir ist zu ohren gekommen
es ist ja witzig was du hast dort
gesprochen über die zukunft der arbeit
ja ich habe über die zukunft der arbeit
gesprochen ich habe michael hüther ne er
war nicht da der mann nicht aber der
vorschlag ja ja die habe ich sofort auch
gelacht sofort auf geht also mich hat
michael hüther
vom institut der deutschen wirtschaft
der hat nicht nur schon mal vor einiger
zeit den vorschlag gemacht dass sie
eigentlich wie es weit über 70 arbeiten
müssten damit in das rentensystem
erhalten bleiben kann sondern wir
sollten in zukunft 42 stunden die woche
arbeiten natürlich mit vollem
lohnausgleich und so ganz normalen also
nicht jetzt keine ausbeutung aber wir
müssen einfach wieder viel mehr arbeiten
und das hat gestern der bdi-präsident
aufgegriffen
und der findet forscher auch ganz toll
jetzt überlege ich mir immer alle leute
wollen eigentlich an dieser zeit von den
ausnahmen abgesehen mehr
work-life-balance mehr zeit für freunde
kinder und so alle wollen weniger
arbeiten flexibler arbeiten und jetzt
kommt die ganz große rolle rückwärts ins
zwanzigste jahr unmöglich und der
einzige grund warum man diese rolle
rückwärts machen will ist um das
rentensystem so wie es heute ist zu
erhalten kann man es nicht umgekehrt
machen und wasser finden system ändern
warum ist gedanke eigentlich sehr schwer
naja ich meine industrielle revolution
haben immer dazu geführt dass die leute
weniger arbeiten mussten jetzt kommt die
nächste industrielle revolution die
leute wunderbaren müssen noch weniger
arbeiten jetzt müssen wir nur wegen
dieser blöden rente länger arbeiten also
das hat schon was ungemein trotzdem ist
hat es aber ist nicht das zweite
argument uns gehen ja die arbeiter aus
also die berühmte arbeitslosigkeit ich
meine ist das nicht irre dass wir jetzt
ich hätte das in meinem leben nicht für
möglich gehalten wird sind wir beide so
in der rushhour wir sind passiert wie
best age eindeutig festgestellt dass
silver surfer und jetzt erleben wir
plötzlich nachdem wir über jahrzehnte
hinweg immer die erfahrung gemacht haben
mehr mehr mehr bis hin dass dann
plötzlich amazon übernommen hat und
dieses gefühl alles und jederzeit
verfügbar
und plötzlich stehen wir dann sagen also
erwarte man jetzt müssen wir uns daran
gewöhnen dass das in zukunft
wahrscheinlich so nicht mehr sein wird
ist eine völlig neue erfahrung mangel an
arbeitskräften jaja mangel mangel an
fachkräften mangel an produkten mangel
an gas jaja an einer energieversorgung
ist und so weiter also dass wir ihn
jetzt in plötzlich in der maßlosen
überflussgesellschaft in so einem mangel
status kommen das kommt eben so ein
bisschen wie geträumt hast du ja also
wir kennen nur das meer wir kennen doch
alle müssen jetzt einige kennenlernen
und das zu vielen ich bin jahrgang 64
der geburten stärkste jahrgang der
wunderstoff wir waren immer zu viel
46 kinder in der grundschulklasse wir
haben immer die erfahrung gemacht es gab
lehrstellenmangel
das war die generation wo die unis an
ihre kapazitätsgrenzen kamen weil in
köln wo ich studiert er plötzlich 5 1000
leute studiert haben die uni war so für
20 25.000 geplant es war also immer zu
viele da und jetzt ist plötzlich
verbreitet zu wenig da das kannte man
aus der ddr hier wirklich nur ist doch
verrückt was ist das was wir gerade
erleben ist das
systemisches versagen wird da etwas
kommt da so ein system an seine grenzen
ich würde sagen ja also es kommt ja in
ganz anderen bereichen an seine grenzen
ich glaube die wirklich dramatisches der
grenze ist dies logisch steckt wenn sie
anhand alle anderen können sich auch
wieder ändern also ich glaube dass es
wieder phasen geben wird der
arbeitsmarkt sich anders und neu
eingespielt und ich glaube ja auch dass
ein bisschen arbeitslosigkeit dazu kommt
durch das werk den wegfall der geistigen
routinearbeiten dass das aber nichts
nützt beim fachkräftemangel aber
arbeitsmärkte sind ja immer in dynamiken
begriffen denke mal an die zeit als sie
die ganzen gastarbeiter geholt haben da
waren ja auch nicht genug leute da in
80er jahren hatten wir dann über zwei
millionen arbeitslosen und das kann sich
sehr schnell verändern deswegen würde
ich sagen dass es eigentlich nicht
system ist aber dass wir im augenblick
sonne so eine umbruchzeit an mehreren
fronten gleichzeitig so nah das macht
irgendwie das lebensgefühl im augenblick
so dramatisch das finde ich auch und was
wir ja auch erleben ist eigentlich ja
die rückabwicklung der globalisierung
was man glaube ich nicht wirklich ich
glaube dass schon mehr ich glaube das
nicht ich glaube die globalisierung wird
fortgesetzt das rein ideelle für eine
der meist um ja aber glaubst also ich
komme am anfang bei krone hat man gesagt
das ist möglicherweise das ende des
kreuzfahrttourismus oder des
massentourismus und so wir werden daraus
lernen ideologisch sehr und ich meine es
ist rappelvoll alles ist es alles sie
vorher system und ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass auch was die
globalisierung anbelangt in einigen
jahren alles wieder wie vorher ist dass
das system ist darauf angewiesen zu
machen auch er auch global gewachsen und
so so eine regionalisierung
wir sind in diesem system nicht
vorgesehen also wenn man es ganz ganz
holzschnittartig zehn jahren
kapitalismus hat sich von england aus ja
immer weiter ausgebreitet bereitet ohne
jede dauerhaft
gebremst zu werden
seit einer phasenweise auch weltkriege
und solche sachen und das wird
weitergehen
ich finde es ja schon interessant wenn
man mal hinguckt in china zum beispiel
die architektin gibt als losung ganz
offizielle aus wir müssen auch tag
werden die amerikaner ich meine trump
der hat von nichts anderem geredet wir
amerikanische portal der freuen wenn
seit den 50er jahren auf familien der
sendung sitzt jede woche irgendein
verantwortlicher politiker der sagt
natürlich sein dass wir nicht mehr in
der lage sind selber masken selber
medikamente selber halbleiter also usw
batterien
die die empörung darüber dass jetzt die
die die letzte fabrik in rostock
abgewickelt wird die rotorblätter für
windmühlen machten ist doch irre also
wir betreiben einerseits die
energiewende und sind andererseits in
ganz europa nicht in der lage
einen an eine windmühle firma eine
produktion auf was die profitabel
weniger bei solarzellen sie zu ähnlichen
taten waren wir waren lagen wir vorne
und irgendwann waren wir gar nicht mehr
im spiel das meine ich und ich habe
schon das gefühl dass dass da etwas
rückabgewickelt wird einfach deswegen
weil leute fragen stellen weil leute
wissen wollte wo kommt das her mit china
geschäfte machen einfach um jeden preis
da werden konsumenten kritisch oder
gucken leute genauer hin neue
transportwege so es gab ja immer ein
starkes ökologisches also genau zu sagen
was ist wenn wir das zeug über die halbe
welt verschiffen was ihr im grunde
genommen selber herstellen das weil ich
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
wir in der lage sein werden alles das
was fehlt er in eigenproduktion in
zukunft zu machen bei fällt mir der
glauben ja mir fehlt insofern die
fantasie als ich immer denke das
bedeutet ja definitiv dass alles teurer
werden wir werden dafür ein preis
bezahlt und in dem moment wo es ans
portemonnaie geht so die inflation noch
weiter steigen weil du an die dinge
nicht mehr ran kommst und sie dann umso
teurer bezahlen musste aber es ein
mangel gibt
glaube ich in dem moment wird conny
kollidieren die westlichen
gesellschaften deutschland nicht als
erstes das ist klar aber über usa wir
viel gesprochen eine eine gesellschaft
an der kante und frankreich man denke an
das jüngste ergebnis der
parlamentswahlen ihre gehört das land
ist ja fast ohne regier wahr geworden
und wir haben die direkte stimmung in
england gesehen wir sehen diese
merkwürdigen regierung jeder in italien
aufeinander folgen also es ist ja nicht
so als ob die die industrieländer des
westens nicht vor
möglicherweise dramatischen inneren
verhältnissen stehen deutschland ist da
noch gemäßigter ja und es gibt andere
länder die sind völlig
problemfrei ja dänemark oder schweden
oder so aber auch in deutschland ist der
sprengstoff da wo liegt da nur noch mehr
ich glaube dass er daran die das durch
die ökonomischen veränderungen die
mittelschicht in der mitte
durchgeschnitten wird ist glaube ich
auch die obere mittelschicht ist das
recht und die untere mittelschicht also
wird nach unten bereichen und
deutschland hat er diese sehr satte gute
zwiebel vom ja das heißt also die breite
ist jetzt der bevölkerung war weil die
mittelschicht wenig unterschied wenig
oberschicht breite mittelschicht und
dann kommt dieser dieser sanduhr effekt
ja dass die kräfte die zwiebel
zusammenpressen und das sind dann
irgendwann die strukturen wie die
schwellenländer oder so dass haben und
dass eines der gründe ist erwärmen und
vererben aber das andere sind auch diese
wirtschaftlichen entwicklungen das aus
geld geld mache nicht so schwer ist ja
nur hat man keins hat zu geld zu kommen
ausgesprochen schwer ist und wir eben
auch früher waren wir so ein aufstiegs
land ja von der unterschicht in die
mittelschicht und das sind wir schon
sehr lange nicht mehr weil die
unterschicht ja nicht die arbeitende
bevölkerung ist sondern diejenigen die
abseits des arbeitsmarkt richtig
und da kommen gegen england kannst du
das hier in england england und
frankreich sind deswegen beide viel
weiter fortgeschritten weil die keinen
zweiten weltkrieg verloren haben genug
bei uns wurde nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
für viele die karten neu gemischt ja da
ging also ganz viele figuren auf einmal
wieder zurück auf los das hat er in
england und frankreich nicht geblieben
die in der schloss erleben da wo sie
vorher schon waren so ist da und
herrchen hater gesellschaften werden um
so natürlicher ist es das reiche reicher
werden und arme in relation erm genau
das sind die normalen kräfte genau weil
ja auch ist ja auch interessant mir dass
man ökonomie klärt und sagte du musst
dir klar machen jedem euro guthaben
steht irgendwo ein euro schuld gegenüber
und umgekehrt natürlich
und und irgendwann wenn der prozess weit
genug fortgeschritten ist haben diese
euro guthaben draufsteht diese
verhängnisvolle fatale tendenz immer
dahin zu gehen wo ohnehin schon
unfassbar findet ihr letztes mal darüber
dass ich es ja dfb boss und andere ja
das ist ja einfach in den etwas was eben
diesen prozess sehr unterstützt ist dass
die realwirtschaft immer bedeutungsloser
wird in relation zur finanzwirtschaft
also der begriff realwirtschaft ist ja
erst in der finanzkrise erfunden worden
den gab es ja vorher gar nicht plötzlich
fällt einem auf dass die
finanzwirtschaft viel größer ist der
ballon viel größer ist als der der
normalen wirtschaft die jetzt plötzlich
mit realwirtschaft quasi auch so einen
kleinen namen kriegt
und dieses auseinandergehen das
verstärkte natürlich den effekt das abo
geld es mehr geld hinzu kommt und das
ist wiederum verstärkt diesen santoro
effekt noch das sind ja auch dann leute
denen die idee deren als großvermieter
auftreten in ganzer straßenzüge häuser
gehören und mit diesem geld an einer
börse arbeiten kinder und für die
normale bevölkerung bei oft genug
darüber geredet man polizisten und
krankenschwester können in großstädten
nicht mehr leben und das alles enthält
sozialen springst ja also ich kriege
jetzt somit wenn man mit menschen
spricht die noch relativ kleine mieten
bezahlen mit dir sagen 'du ich hatte
jetzt gerade abrechnung 200 euro mehr
und so weiter bei den nebenkosten dann
geht es plötzlich zur sache jetzt schon
und das glaube ich auch da da da da
liegt ein erheblicher sprengstoff
trainer ja und über allem richard immer
noch ukraine naja ich musste immer was
vorlesen die frage ist welchen preis ist
man bereit für den frieden zu bezahlen
wieviel landfläche wie viel
unabhängigkeit wie viele souveränität
wie viel freiheit wie viel demokratie
ist man bereit zu opfern für den frieden
das ist unser sehr schwieriges
moralisches dilemma von wem stammt aus
kommst du nie so hoch also ich würde
sagen dass das was olaf scholz denkt der
hat aber wahrscheinlich nicht gesagt
nein aber ich würde das absolute
unterschreiben aber weißt du von gm das
ist und das ist das interessante ist
kommt am ende ein historisches zitat
wenn ich jens stoltenberg ok jetzt
stoltenberg der nato generalsekretär
also da machen sich leute gedanken über
die frage wie geht es denn weiter
offensichtlich sollte merck hat ja auch
etwas zu meiner überraschung und ich
vermute ein taktischer satz gesagt dass
der krieg noch jahre dauert das glaube
ich nicht glaubst du nicht nein das
glaube ich nicht
das glaube ich nicht also warum glaubst
du das nicht
so langsam die russen vorwärtskommen so
kontinuierlich kommen sie vorwärts und
jedes dieser verschossenen dörfer von
hier wäre dann jetzt angefangen über die
demnächst über bach mut und wir werden
in die städte wie finanzen und grammatik
hinein
verringert sich der frontabschnitt
das heißt wir haben jetzt mit jeder
ausbuchtung 2400 kilometer frontlinie
und wir werden weniger und damit können
die russen ihre kräfte stärker bündeln
und mit ihrem wahnsinnig überlegen den
artilleriebeschuss noch im verhältnis
zur ukraine eins zu zwanzig werden die
kontinuierlich weiter vorwärts kommen
und dann ist die frage ich meine wir die
ukraine sagen im augenblick denn sie
haben 50 prozent ihres kriegs materials
verloren jetzt schon dann ist völlig
klar dass sie diesen krieg verlieren und
die spannende frage wird sein dass wenn
die russen
ihr plan b kriegsziel erreicht haben
also lohans und man jetzt erobert haben
dann werden die großen in die
friedensverhandlungen und werden sagen
so bis dahin sind wir gekommen ihr habt
kein richtig einsatzfähiger mia ja und
jetzt entweder erfüllt hier die dinge
die wir von anfang an von euch wollten
obergrenze bei eurer armee kein
nato-beitritt usw oder wir gehen weiter
das ist das szenario dass auch die
westlichen staatschefs vor augen kilo
das war ja auch sehr interessant nur
dieser hass das mitgekriegt genauer
verfolgt hattest du die zeit diesem
besuch makro ja dass gerade natürlich
sehr interessiert und ich hätte gern
gewusst wer über sie geredet haben sie
und hab das gefühl viel habe ich nicht
erfahren nee das ist das eigentlich
fertig auch die die macht der bilder
fand ich so uninteressant also ich find
es gab so viele kleine momente ich habe
gestern abend länger mit paul ronzheimer
telefoniert liebe grüße an der stelle
der gerade in den weg auf den weg in den
osten ist und
respekt davor weil es wichtig ist glaube
ich zu verstehen was dort eigentlich
tatsächlich passiert und wenn man mit
ihm spricht dann beschreibt er die genau
was da passiert das eigentlich die
russen einfach alles zu preisschießen
das was du gerade angedeutet ist hass
artillerie verhältnis 20 zu 1 munition
sogar 40 der die eingangs
munitionsdepots noch gejagt bevor sie
losgehen angefangen er erzählte mir von
vom ukrainischen soldaten die ist kann
man gar nicht glauben in den krieg an
die front geschickt werden mit sechs
magazin patronen und die sich dann war
fast gegen wen sollen die sich verdi die
ich hier die bilder gesehen also die
heben ihre eigenen särge aus indem sie
die und schützen so schützengräben
kilometertief zwei meter breit da sitzen
die un sollen ja ja die russischen
raketen auf den artillerie so und weil
es im offenen gelände sowieso nicht geht
dennoch verlagert die ukraine den krieg
in die städte richtig da putin sicher
noch immer als befreier der ost ukraine
sieht würde der natürlich sehr gerne
verhindert dass der krieg in den städten
statt vernichten damit einen irrsinnigen
schaden bei den menschen auch
zivilbevölkerung und sollen das ganze
land kaputt geht
die ukraine ag mit absicht in die städte
weil man im häuserkampf immer noch eine
chance hat die russen länger aufzuhalten
als wenn man sich auf irgendeinen fällt
ein kriegsheld einfach nur wartet bis
man lebendig begraben wird genau das
führt natürlich zu der perverse
situation dass um den krieg zu
verlangsamen man die zahl der opfer von
ukrainischer seite erhöht genauer das
heißt also man nötigt seiner bevölkerung
immer größere opfer ab
verständlicherweise aus dem motiv besser
im krieg dazu stehen aber unverständlich
unter der perspektive den krieg nicht
gewinnen zu können das ist irre wenn du
weißt gerade gruselige situationen weil
du gerade opfer sagt zahlen sagt die
kollegen von der süddeutschen die haben
das mal ausgerückt die haben das mal
versucht zusammenzutragen seit dem
beginn des krieges sagt die ukraine
haben die russen fast 5000 tanzer
verloren hunderte flugzeuge helikopter
und ungefähr die zahlen sind immer mit
großer vorsicht zu genießen ist mir klar
aber
33.000 soldaten das halte ich für
denkbar ich glaube auf der ukrainischen
seite ist es mittlerweile ähnlich und
das sind einfach zahlen dazu bestimmt
was ich nicht in ähnlicher zahl
zivilisten das muss man sich mal
vorstellen dann einfach unter 1000 tote
ja und hinter jedem toten ein drama eine
familie eine geschichte angehörige ein
vater so ja die geschichte eines jungen
mannes gehört der ukraine sehr roman
heißt er glaube ich sehr sehr populär
der gefallen ist 24 jahre alte war schon
auf dem majdan mit dabei war einer von
dem man sagt der hat theoretisch das
potenzial irgendwann mal vielleicht
sogar präsident der ukraine so werden
der es jetzt gefallen und dass das
perfide daran sein vater fährt am tag
der beerdigung am selben abend noch
zurück an die front also in sachen lage
sind die provider ist sehr
unterschiedlich sind also ich glaube
dass die die anzahl derjenigen die mit
aller macht ihr vaterland verteidigen
wollen weniger werden sagte in sagen die
ukraine selber die soll klinische
general der gesagt hat dass 50 prozent
des militärs der ukraine zerstört ist er
hat auch gesagt dass die moral der
truppen schlechter wird das ist ein
erstaunlicher sei es dass er wieder so
was im krieg selber als unreiner zu
sagen es ist ja sehr ungewiss mir ist
das motiv nicht klar ich weiß nicht was
sicherlich nicht mit seinen ski
abgestimmt aber wen wundert es noch also
wenn man weiß dass dieser krieg nicht
gewonnen würden dass man also den
aggressor zurückschlägt und nicht
vertreibt und am besten auch die krim
zurückerobert sondern es ist nur eine
frage ist bis wohin der geht
und dass man das mit waffengewalt eben
nicht aufhalten kann sondern dass diese
frage am ende nicht in den
schützengräben weiß hier wäre wenn jetzt
entschieden wird sondern dass den
verhandlungstischen unter aktiver
mithilfe des westens entschieden wird wo
soll denn diese motivation noch
dauerhaft wirkungen das ist der punkt
wie gestern auch mit mit paul renz haben
darüber gesprochen er sagte du musst du
das so vorstellen da sind diese straßen
sind zum großen teil nicht mehr
befahrbar sagt vivi wie fatih denn dann
da rainha feldwege die sind aber häufig
verdient das heißt du fährst da über
feldwege und weiß nicht genau wann das
ding in die luft fliegt
wasserleitungen systematisch zerstört
infrastruktur systematisch zerstört das
heißt du weißt gar nicht genau was
trinkst du da überhaupt ja wann dann
fängst du dir diese krankheit ein und so
weiter oder stirbst einfach an
schlechtem wasser
und und dann diese sechs patronen
661 aber markus unterrainer das macht
doch keinen sinn ja ja andererseits und
das ist jetzt der andere punkt
andererseits sagt nicht nur paul
ronzheimer selbst die russischsprachigen
ukraine und ich glaube das unterschätzen
wir nach wie vor die 2014 zum teil die
russen durchaus als befreier begrüßt
haben selbst die wollen heute nicht mehr
befreit werden unter anführungszeichen
da werden wir das so ganz genau wüssten
da soll ich glaube dass jemand der dort
gerade ist und der diese situation dort
sehr sehr gut kennt und der sagt
unterschätzt nicht die moral der ukraine
die verstehen die haben nichts mehr zu
verlieren da geht es um leben und
sterben und es geht um die frage wie
wollen wir weiter leben
und da müssen wir vielleicht mal in die
leeren und der preis den die bis dahin
bezahlt haben also boccia der die diese
unvorstellbaren gräueltaten die
vergewaltigungen alles was da war der
preis ist mittlerweile so hoch aber der
wird höher gelegen hat der krieg weil
ich weiss aber es gibt trotzdem nicht zu
gewinnen das ist ja die verzweifelte
lage ja ich kann ja nicht sagen weil
butscher passiert ist führen wir ein
krieg den wir nicht gewinnen weiß also
was das was ich immer schwierig finde in
der diskussion ist immer die frage und
da sind machen wir es uns zu leicht wir
sind die ukraine
also es gibt die ukrainische regierung
es gibt das haben ja gesehen am anfang
sehr viele bilder davon junge leute oft
manche ältere leute die bereit sind mit
feuer und schwert ihr land zu
verteidigen
ich sehe aber auch all diese filme wenn
der krieg der ostukraine in die dörfer
und die kleinen städte getragen wird das
den bauern völlig unpolitische bauern
genau ja die sind die russischstämmige
sind oder ukraine für mich beides sind
oder wie auch immer die haben einfach
nur angst ihr kleines häuschen zu
verlieren selber zu sterben dass ihre
äcker und felder die ver.di ihre
existenz ist verwüstet werden und so
weiter dass die alle jetzt beseelt davon
sind den russischen fein
zurückzuschlagen das glaube ich
überhaupt nicht sondern ich glaube für
diese leute ist das beste was ihnen
passieren kann ja wenn kein krieg in
ihrer stadt kommt und ich glaube dass
das eben augenblick in kriegsgebieten
die meisten menschen sind ja das
gegenargument ist richard und deswegen
denke ich mal wir sind dazu schnell in
unserem urteil
wenn du hörst wie sozusagen systematisch
auch alles was ukrainisch ausgelöst wird
wenn du erlebst wie schulbücher
umgeschrieben werden wenn du lebst wie
die sprache verboten wird wenn du
erlebst wie deine kinder plötzlich
sozusagen systematisch von kleinen
ukraine zu kleinen russen vorher war es
umgekehrt wie du weißt das was die
ukraine vorher gegenüber den russen
macht haben in der ukraine jetzt genauso
wie doch genau so ideologisch rumgedreht
ja ja das kann ich wiederum nicht so
richtig beurteilen aber vom prinzip her
folge ich dem gedanken was mitgekriegt
dass gerade keine russische musik mehr
gespielt werden darf im ukrainischen
radio fernsehen überhaupt nicht mehr
alles russische wird verboten
also der ukraine und verdenken ja ich
will nur sagen dass meine ja also ich
weiß es geht auch nicht darum dass ich
jetzt den zeigefinger hebt nicht nur
sagen im hinblick auf quasi die ächtung
der jedes jeweils anderen kultur da tun
sich nichts
und trotzdem ist für mich immer weil ich
glaube schon dass man immer klar haben
muss woher die aggression kommt und wer
das ganze vom sound gebrochen hat und
wer dort rein das sei ihre eigene idee
dass jetzt doch nicht streitig machen
das doch nicht strittig benutzer bei
aller diskussion das ist mir wichtig zu
sagen ja auch werden ihnen unterschieden
die wir in manchen betrachtungsweisen
haben niemand in deutschland die nicht
kenne und der sich öffentlich zu wort
gemeldet hat hat irgendeinen zweifel
daran wer hier der aggressor ist ja
liebe keine es gibt keine moralische
differenz im sinne von dir eine
verteidigte ihn und der andere
verteidigten ja alle verteidigen die
ukraine sondern die frage über die wir
diskutieren ist was ist das richtige
mittel für die menschen in der ukraine
das ist die frage wird er wir streiten
wir streiten doch nicht über moral wir
streiten darüber ob diese
waffenlieferungen ein positives ziel
erreichen können oder ob sie die sache
schlimmer machen das ist doch keine
moralische frage dafür ist es doch eine
frage der abschätzung der wirksamkeit
eines mittels für eine gute sache genau
und meint punkt ist und deswegen kommen
wir nochmal zudem zu diesem treffen wird
der 3 oder der vier sogar der rumänische
staatschef auch dabei
was wird dort eigentlich wirklich
vorbereitet und was wird eigentlich der
öffentlichkeit wirklich gesagt makro
zwei tage vorher in rumänien glaube ich
truppenbesuch sagt da müssen uns gar
nichts vormachen so wie es laufen wir
werden uns selbstverständlich jetzt bald
an den verhandlungstisch setzen und kurz
davor putin darf nicht gedemütigt werden
und wir alle verstehen die hat den
gedanken dass 1 gedemütigt dass russland
ein wirtschaftlich am boden liegendes
russland ist ja auch so
dass das umso gefährlicher wird je mehr
man ist demütigend das ist mir völlig
klar dass das verstehe ich alles nichts
desto trotz ist die frage was wird da im
hintergrund gerade vorbereitet also ist
sozusagen eigentlich schon fast
beschlossene sache dass man den osten
der ukraine ehrmann abspaltet und
vermute ja und das bonbon dafür ist
sozusagen ein neuer kreativer
startschuss ist ein großer unterschied
also ich glaube die gesichtswahrung
frage ist kratie wichtigsten genau die
gesichtswahrung frage ist die
gesichtswahrung für putin jetzt ist die
gesichtswahrung selensky es ist die
gesichtswahrung frage für den westen der
der mit waffen unterstützungen diesen
krieg gewinnen wollte und ihn vermutlich
so nicht gewinnen wird so und jeder muss
sehen dass er auf seine art und weise
gesund aus der sache rauskommt es ist
uns nicht erzielt worden worüber die so
lange geredet haben aber sehenswert in
der pressekonferenz gesagt dass er sich
friedensverhandlungen ab august
vorstellen könnte jetzt gehe ich mal
schwer davon aus würde mich doch sehr
täuschen wer sowas ja warum sagt ja
sowas als wenn die frage muss und
gewesen sein mag ronny scholz haben ihn
gefragt wann und unter welchen
bedingungen bist du zu
friedensverhandlungen bereit und dann
wird er wohl gesagt haben eure waffen
sind ja zum großen teil nicht angekommen
lasst es doch noch mal versuchen im
süden eine große gegenoffensive zu
machen und vielleicht gelingt es uns ja
da noch was zurückzuerobern dann stehen
wir besser da wenn wir jetzt in
friedensverhandlungen gehen dann werden
die russen sagen also dass die ost und
der süd ukraine russisch ist da brauchen
wir nicht mehr darüber zu diskutieren
jetzt diskutieren wir ja nur noch über
die frage was aus dem rest wird und das
wäre für sie links gehen natürlich eine
katastrophe
ja weil dann ist ja nicht mehr der große
nationalheld der ukraine egal wie
aufrüttelnd er die weltgemeinschaft
mobilisiert hat sondern es hat der
präsident genau der ein fünftel des
landes verloren hat und sogar noch die
wirtschaftlich das wichtigste fünft als
als ukrainischer präsident
spitzenpolitiker kannst du keinem sagen
wir stimmen dem zu ich nehme an dass er
dennoch fürchten muss dass das er nicht
präsident bleibt wie zum beispiel die
opposition gegen ihn gewinnt glaube ich
24 glaube ich haben die wahl
weil es unter den bedingungen der wahl
überhaupt stattfindet ja mal muss ich
nicht so sich genau man muss man muss an
vitali klitschko denken der 2014 weiter
an ich glaube vitali klitschko wäre
möglicherweise präsident der ukraine
geworden wenn er nicht janukowitsch
irgendwann an einem bestimmten punkt
unterstützt hätte und als der plötzlich
abgehauen ist war vitali klitschko der
verräter der ukraine aber der könnte
sozusagen politischen mittel
potenzieller nachfolger ja absolut jetzt
in wird jetzt mehr über diese nachfolger
frage die es noch werden sie nicht weit
weil noch nicht nicht spekulieren aber
ich denke mal das ist ein unterschied
gibt zwischen dem was jemand wie scholz
und microsoft records sagt was der held
einer verschlossenen türen mit zellen
skibbe spricht da wird ja nicht den satz
sagen die ukraine wird gewinnen den
annalena baerbock gerade so häufig
trotzig wiederholt samstag den ja gar
nicht mehr sagt den gar nicht weil da
darf nicht glauben so denn bei uns
extrem angefeindet und das ist einfach
nur realismus ja ich glaube der satz der
der häufigere satz heißt dann immer
russland darf den krieg nicht gewinnen
ich glaube das ist die vorsicht der
sanierung und dann wird man am ende
einen langen alles um die frage machen
was ist gewinnen
aber die die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
diese ostgebiete weg sind hier ist groß
so jetzt biete ich mal zwei perspektiven
dorfen das eine ist die moralische
entrüstung da nur dass dieser
angriffskrieg belohnt worden ist
ermittelt ja das also russland den
zugang zum song jetzt becken gänzlich
gekriegt hat den süden noch
strategischen zugang zum meer und dass
er quasi ungestraft ja diesen
fürchterlichen angriffskrieg geworden
dass perspektive 1 hat mal wieder
funktioniert hat mal wieder ein bisschen
ihren guten alten zeitungen wie man
früher wie maria grimm wie in georgien
auch wie man überhaupt ihr früher in
europa kriege geführt hat so hat
bismarck deutschland groß gemacht das
war realpolitik und das haben wir gesagt
das hat nichts mehr am 21 jahrhundert
verloren die zweite perspektive ist wenn
ich schon bismarck saal saß lothringen
war zwischen deutschland und frankreich
über jahrhunderte umkämpft und die frage
wem das gehört schon eine existenzielle
frage
spanische erbfolgekrieg
religionskriege erster weltkrieg krieg
von 70 71 zweiter weltkrieg niemals
wieder ja wahrscheinlich hunderttausende
im laufe der geschichte menschen sind
finden diese frage gestorben wo die
grenze zwischen deutschland und
frankreich liegen heute ist es die
unwichtigste frage der welt nichts wäre
anders wenn elsass lothringen zu
deutschland gehört oder ob es zu
frankreich gehört wir haben die ukraine
jetzt gar nichts von aber das wird
möglicherweise dann die
betrachtungsweise und 50 jahren in 50
jahren dass das den standpunkt
das ding ist halt etwas ändert nichts an
perspektive 1 ja ja ja genau ich hab'
ich habe also die diese bilder die wir
eben gesprochen haben ich fand das so
ihre wir machen der sendung kurz drüber
geredet am donnerstag
du siehst selensky in diesem t-shirt ja
in diesem olivfarbenen und dann siehst
du makro scholz draghi alle mit anzug
und krawatte und die absurden bilder und
da stehen diese drei staatschefs in
anzug und krawatte ja mit mit mit
perfect gestärktem kragen und
blütenweißen hemd in ihr team
fast so hilflos dieses abgebrannte
autowrack an und man denkt ja genau das
irgendwo sucht den fehler im bild also
dass das kriegt man so nicht zusammen
aber natürlich hat das eine botschaft
und ich höre hinter den kulissen soll es
makro gewesen sein der auf krawatte auch
bestand und ich habe überlegt mehr ja
geklebt werden nur ganz kurz in dem
streifen anderen gedanken hinaus ich
will sagen richard wenn du da
hemdsärmliger auftritt sagt so was
anderes als wenn du in anzug und
krawatte kommt für mich ist anzug und
krawatte us diplomatie ist verhandlung
erinnerst du dich an dieses bild olaf
scholz die meine der hätte sie lenski
gar nicht umarmen können wie es andere
gemacht haben weil er doch seinen lehrer
attentate hat in der linken hand hatte
ja dass das war ja sehr interessant also
diese maximale distanz ja bestimmt
überhaupt nicht böse gemeint und ich
weiß das was ich auch aus persönlichen
begegnungen olaf scholz ist zu viel mehr
emotionen und empathie in der lage als
man öffentlich so weiß
nicht so genau die hat aber eine sehr
verbindliche angenehme seite aber er
weiß genau um die macht der bilder und
wenn man das so sieht dann hat man schon
den eindruck okay das geht jetzt alles
in eine ganz bestimmte richtung das
glaube ich hab hast du diesen es gab
doch diesen diesen ihren moment als
scholz zum schluss sagt der es lebe die
ukraine auf ukrainisch das kann man so
sagen aber wie er das gesagt hat dass
dich das glaubte noch nicht mal selbst
was man so emotionslos
das war nichts das sagte also einig und
carina wäre ja das hören würde ich
denken gut okay also ist das nicht
richtig fest davon überzeugt und ich
sagte ihm sei so ich bin absolut fest
davon überzeugt dass seine empathie und
seine sympathie der ukraine der garage
frage ob der vertrag aber dass der
realpolitiker genug ist genug einem
bombastischen gesten eck seine taten
nicht einholen kann von sich zu geben
auch wenn die presse die fordert und
auch wenn er weiß dass die opposition
kapital versucht daraus zu schlagen um
ihn als als schwächling oder als
wankelmütigen an zu stellen er hat ja
den satz gesagt ich meine hätte den auf
die verfassung geschworen schaden vom
deutschen volk abzuwenden und das ist ja
auch die erste aufgabe eines eines
bundeskanzlers und ich denke den besten
dienst der ukraine tun kann besteht
nicht in symbolischen bildern sondern
besteht wirklich in konstruktiven
friedensgesprächen die werden nicht gut
für die ukraine ausfallen also ist die
frage ist die wahl zwischen pest und
cholera es ist die frage des kleineren
und des größeren übels und markus ich
weiß ich bin doch erst gefällt ein ich
hoffe du weißt was ich gemeint wenn wir
wenn wir mal die die die öffentlichkeit
uns anschauen die veröffentlich kite und
die öffentlichkeit wir hatten am anfang
bestürzt es war die erste phase dann
ganz schnell verständlicherweise
entrüstung
dann kam der dritte schritt mut und
hoffnung ja weil die russen plötzlich
nicht mehr vorwärts gab und jetzt haben
wir die phase trotz
trotz also wir wiederholen trotz sich
die ukraine muss den krieg gewinnen wir
werden waffen liefern und und und und
und und die nächste phase wird dann die
phase der diplomatie sein
was ja also wenn man mit militär
experten darüber rede ist ja ganz
interessant für die es die sache nicht
so klar die sagen schaut doch mal genau
hin also kleinere städte da arbeiten die
sich mühsam langsam vor die russin die
haben auch enorme verluste erlitten jahr
20 bis 30 prozent seiner armee für eine
kapazität werde die verlierst hat teils
teils schlimmen schwierig mit den zahlen
aber wir haben ja ein ordentlicher
verlust nicht verzeiht das ist gar kein
das wurde ja sogar in russland auch
durchaus diskutiert und einen sehr sehr
blutigen preisen fast unfassbar wobei
man auch eben sagen muss die russische
öffentlichkeit ist noch gelenk durch
diese diese absolute öl laufen die
propagandamaschinerie keinster weise
empört entrüstet und sozusagen zum
aufstand oder zum widerstand bereit
sondern das geht alles zu tun ich das
hatten wir in der phase einer mut und
hoffnung da haben wir auf die
wirtschaftliche sanktionen würden
schnell greifen wir haben hier darüber
geredet der wirtschaftsleistung von
italien und der gesamte westen
boykottiert russland von ein paar
ausnahmen abgesehen aber zum größten
teil das muss doch klappen jetzt haben
sie wieder ein riesen dealen mit china
abgeschlossen ja wir haben die
chinesisch russische allianz zwei länder
die sich eigentlich nicht leiden können
intensiviert auch das hat alles ja nicht
funktioniert die haben da noch gehofft
der lieth oligarchen kutschen gegen
putin und so wir sehen uns getrogen mit
diesem hobby ja wir haben gesagt die
russen aber jetzt die inflation ist
haben sie plötzlich selber
und der unterschied ist kann der
wichtige unterschied ist du kannst in
russland kann es passieren dass die
bevölkerung ein einbruch von 20 30
prozent beim wohlstand ja kriegt und es
passiert gar nichts mehr als 20 prozent
von nichts ja ja gut ist ist immer noch
dreimal mehr als in der ukraine ja
servus das russische
bruttoinlandsprodukt pro kopf ist doch
immer dreimal höher als in der ukraine
aber egal rechnerischen rechnerisch es
gab noch nie gerechtigkeit in diesem
land ja es gab noch nie mit bestimmungen
in diesem lande es gibt gar keine
fairness erwartungen in russland bei uns
glaubt das ganz hohe fairness
erwartungen zu recht aber wir sind ein
ganz sensibles system bei uns steigt im
nächsten winter der heizkreise und die
leute mehr ändern ihre weltanschauung
also der westen ist hier fragt nach
russland obwohl russland wirtschaftlich
so schwach und das ist ich war das wäre
der schlimmste motiv wo man seine
meinung zum krieg ändert ist weil man
friert ja aber realistisch ist sowas
möglich du was du da sagst dass das
klingt vielleicht für den einen oder
anderen zynisch aber ich weiß das wird
auch in der berliner politik genau das
wird diskutiert dass er das ist die
große an klasse ist sodann als zynisch
man könnte das na ja man könnte sagen
was man auf es ist natürlich zynisch
wenn da leute um ihr nacktes überleben
kämpfen und um ihr nacktes leben laufen
und wir machen uns gedanken darüber ob
es für uns warm genug war aber ich habe
ich mal des hessischen empfinde deswegen
habe ich habe ich die formulierung war
das auch mit absicht also zu den gründen
die für mich ja gegen waffenlieferungen
sprechen gehört nicht dass wir im winter
friert so und auch nicht dass wir eine
inflation haben die in erster linie von
den corona mitteln kommt und nur mit
einem kleinen teil mit dem ukraine krieg
zu genau die stärksten argumente dagegen
ist dass dieser krieg mutmaßlich nicht
zu gewinnen ist sondern nur noch mehr
menschen ihr leben verlieren und das
zweite starke argument ist dass wir
damit rechnen müssen dass infolge des
krieges in afrika noch mehr menschen
sterben als in der ukraine
das sind zwei sehr starke argumente
dagegen diesen krieg mit allem was man
hat weiterzuführen das argument dass wir
hier wirtschaftseinbruch haben ist für
mich kein argument wir haben auch meine
folge gemacht ich bin ja ein völliger
unterstützer der wirtschaftskommission
aber diese anderen beiden sind sehr
schwerwiegend ja das ist wahr
das ding ist halt
wie geht es dann weiter richtung also
das eine ist das militärisch das wollte
ich eben noch folgen kurze ausführen
also wenn du mit militär leuten sprichst
dann sagen die dir carlo masala habe ich
heute morgen auch gelesen wer sagte und
schätze ich sehr der wer kennt sich
wirklich aus der sagte das ist keine
ausgemachte sache die die die haben
echte probleme mit munition im
speziellen und auch mit diesem
schlechten verhältnis die ukraine den
geht einfach schlicht und ergreifend den
gehen die patronen aus aber wenn wir in
der lage sind sozusagen jetzt in den
nächsten wochen bis ende juni hin zum
beispiel moderne waffensysteme zu
liefern dann werden wir die zumindest in
die lage versetzen dass sie sich wehren
können und deswegen gehen diese leute
das steht völlig diametral zu dem was du
eingangs sagte ist ja die gehen davon
aus dass das eben ein sehr sehr langer
konflikt werden kann ein langer langer
krieg also über jahre hinweg menge vor
kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen wenn
man mal überlegt der krieg ist jetzt
vier monate die ukraine hat nach eigenen
angaben deswegen glaube ich dass jetzt
mal also hier keine russischen angaben
oder so oder vom britischen geheimdienst
das muss man mal sagen das nur drolligen
und der britische geheimdienst der
ständig die öffentlichkeit welche
informationen ich meine jetzt das
gegenteil dessen was die aufgabe eines
geheimdienstes ist der deutsche
geheimdienst äußert sich nie ja also da
ist natürlich wichtig geheimnis der
übrigens auch von der saturn innerhalb
der ukrainischen armee bericht
inzwischen war mir ja inzwischen aber
trotzdem finde ich dass ich etwas
nebulöse quelle das muss man wirklich
sagen kann geheimdienst ja ständig die
öffentlichkeit informiert er kann es
kein geheimdienst mehr hat was vor also
ich glaube deswegen nicht dass es lange
geht wenn man den vier monaten die
hälfte seiner paar mehr verloren hat und
400 panzer zum beispiel wie viele panzer
müsste man liefern wie viele mehrfach
raketenwerfer müsste man liefern damit
dieser krieg jahre dauert ich glaube das
ist nicht realistisch also der frühjahr
schnitt ist so unglaublich lang dass man
einer ein oder anderen stelle vielleicht
machen durchbruch schafft und man wie
ein bisschen was zurückerobert aber
gleichzeitig verliert man dann ganz hier
in zehn anderen fällen also dass macht
wirklich keinen sinn ich zitiere nochmal
paul ronzheimer der sagt dies ist eine
frage des ziels eine frage dessen
worüber wollen wir dann wirklich
verhandeln also worum geht es da
tatsächlich wenn du sagst die ukraine
darf diesen krieg unter gar keinen
umständen verlieren dann kann das ein
ganz ganz langer krieg wer den wald die
russen auch in den neunzigerjahren
abrüstung und so weiter die haben alles
an sozusagen konventioneller munition
und waffen und die haben alles im ural
und das war einfach weiter in ihren
beständen und liegen lassen wir haben's
abgeräumt wir haben unfall er sage das
ist endlos die können endlos einfach
immer weiter aber irgendwann ist doch
mal die ukrainische armee kaputt ja und
die frage ist wie lange sind wir bereit
sozusagen auch elisa fähig wie häufig
gehört erst mal wie sie haben ihren stil
haben wir abzugeben
amerikaner ist doch genauso endlos ja
und das zweite ist kommt das an und die
enkel
große große blackbox charakter ist nach
wie vor ich glaube nicht daran dass man
in der lage ist panzer oder mehrfach
raketenwerfer in die ukraine liefert ich
glaube dass das nicht geht also bis ich
jemanden treffe er mir erklärt wie das
geht ich hatte mich im moment für dich
jetzt und jetzt lerne ich dazu etwas
ernsthaft und zwar
ich hatte auch immer so diese
vorstellung der wirtin also über polen
kommt ja unfassbar 4 1 an waffen
unfassbar also sie die amerikaner
fliegen da wachsen und waffensysteme
rein das macht man sich glaube ich keine
vorstellung das geht auch ganz ganz
schnell die haben sie die logistik dafür
irak afghanistan die wissen wie das geht
und dann die frage wie kommt das in die
ukraine ja und dann höre ich von von
leuten die sich damit auskennen ich war
nie in der ukraine nicht gehen das
dortige schienen jetzt zb nicht sie
sagen es ist wahnsinnig weit verzweigt
und du wärst du überrascht davon auf wie
vielen geheimen wegen man sehr wohl
schwere waffen und waffensysteme in die
ukraine reihen kritik mit zügen ja also
ich glaub es nicht ich glaube das
hosting raketen das ist ein charakter
ist meter bis meter fünfzig lang die
kanzlei jeden gemüse lkw man kann es
überall rein schmuggeln und ganz am
munition überall hinbringen aber ein
panzer was wie ich ein leopard 60 tonnen
kann ein gepard 50 oder soja mehrfach
raketenwerfer wie 25 tonnen
überlegt ihr mal dass die spurbreite ist
ja unterschiedliche sondern verlagen
werden weder kräne ein verladen und
jetzt macht den zug ja wie viel wie
viele panzer kann es überhaupt aufs huhn
sattelschlepper zug überhaupt machen die
so wahnsinnig schwer sei ja in welchem
tempo kannst du damit von der polnischen
grenze bis in den donnerstag
lang fahren dahin ist nichts mit
verschiedenen netzen ja geheimen routen
usw wir haben das alles auf dem radar
das glaube ich nicht dass das hat
bekommt also ich kann mir vorstellen man
kann viel sagen wollte der hersteller
wegen des waffenschmuggels genau wie
kommen denn in den gazastreifen immer
wieder die was sagen das geht aber das
ist doch keine schweren panzer ja aber
sohn ihres waffensystem zum beispiel
dass damit kannst du eine ganze stadt
verteidigen mit drei mit drei dieser
geräte betreiben also du glaubst nach
wie vor das was ankommt ja davon bin ich
also das ist das was ich also alle drei
vier tage höre ich ja wieder dass die
russen wieder westliche
waffenlieferungen in die luft gejagt
haben ja so monieren die indians jahren
auch die sammelplätze oder das erstmal
angeliefert wird um das entsprechend zu
verteilen also wir müssen mal davon
ausgehen selbst wenn du recht hast und
das ein oder andere kommt an ein
beträchtlicher teil kommt nicht an
offensichtlich
die die frage ist erich hat ich meine
realpolitiker zufolge gesagt das ist ein
total interessanter punkt wenn man jetzt
mal jahre weiter denkt dann
gibt es ja eigentlich für russland genau
zwei optionen irgendwann wird putin
nicht mehr da sein irgendwann wird
dieses land ja faktisch auch den krieg
verloren haben in gewisser weise also
vielleicht jetzt nicht die schlacht um
lukrative um es jetzt mal so zu sagen
aber aber den krieg an sich das wird ein
gedemütigter
komplett ausgebrannt ist die armee
abgewrackt und dezimiert die die
wirtschaftszahlen im keller die die
wirtschaft selber am boden die leute
also das wird an land werden das auf
riesige probleme zusteuert auf riesige
problem dar um das den größten teil der
probleme ohnehin schon hat aber diese
probleme werden sich weiter ernten das
verschlimmert werden und deswegen wird
dieses russland ein gefährliches land
werden weil man nicht genau weiß wo wo
driftet dieses riesige reich
richterlichen dann gibt es große ängste
und das sage ich ja schon sehr häufig
gesagt ein potenzieller putin nachfolger
zum teil noch deutlich gefährlich hat
genau und dann gehts ja genau und da ist
die frage ob wir nicht auch da natürlich
eine verantwortung haben und eigentlich
jetzt schon darauf will ich hinaus die
weichen dafür stellen müssen dass dieses
russland sich sozusagen nicht auf der
dunklen seite der macht wieder findet
weil eigentlich gibt es ja nur zwei ob
meine rede seit ich habe eben im stern
einen essay geschrieben zwei wochen
nachkriegs anfang nicht gesagt hat wir
können uns dauerhaft
der eskalation der freundschaft mit
russland leisten
das klingt natürlich ihn so moment
komisch auf der anderen seite hast du ja
sie reden jetzt über den aggressiven
krieg genannt du hast du hast diesen
putin hat das völkerrecht bricht er du
hast du die verbrechen von butscher und
viele andere die auch noch alles ans
tageslicht kommen werden du hast das
alles und dann im gleichen atemzug zu
sagen wir brauchen aber eine gemeinsame
sicherheitsarchitektur und russland das
klingt merkwürdig aber von der sache her
wäre die alternative dazu und das in uns
das ist das wichtigste was man hier
sagen muss das leben ist eine frage der
alternativ ja und nicht nur die frage
der gesinnung sondern das ist eine frage
daran zu wecken wohin führt welches
mittel wie ich vorhin sagte natürlich
müssen wir dauerhaft irgendwann wieder
und zwar nicht in 100 jahren sondern
hoffentlich in den nächsten 10 in ein
normalisierungsprozess mit russland
kommen wenn ich annalena baerbock höhere
die sagt wir dürfen nie wieder geschäfte
mit russland machen schwieriger sei das
macht die sache doch noch lange maschine
ja was will sie den dritten weltkrieg
dann irgendwann doch ja ich weiss denn
weder putin nachfolger ihrer
ehrenrettung sie hat nicht von
geschäften sondern sie hat von energie
gesprochen von gas gesprochen wir dürfen
wieder von russland abhängig sein wenn
irgendwas um das was ich war so genau
aber du hast habe eigentlich ist ja
gedanke alle reißleine zu kappen und
eigentlich keine fäden mehr zu knüpfen
und lassen und das macht die sache nicht
besser ja weil die andere also die
alternative ist ja der zweite weg kann
ja nur sein dann verbünden sie sich mit
dem autokratischen diktatorischen in
china und da sind sie schon ziemlich
weit gehen und er hat gesagt dass ich da
gar keinen umständen zulassen dürfte ja
und ich meiner mutti in indien japan hat
durchaus fall ist die idee ja also die
drei passen in gewisser hinsicht gut
zusammen und diesen blog ja den will man
sich jetzt eigentlich nicht vorstellen
wir fanden das immer ganz gut dass die
chinesen und die russen sich nicht gut
verstanden haben selbst als er sich
beide noch kommunistischen an
ich hab nur nicht richtig verschiebung
ja diese geostrategischen verschiebung
da ist nicht viel gutes dran genau da
hast du recht und ich glaube halt
deswegen habe ich das thema grad auf
gemacht oder den gedanken ich glaube
dass leute wie scholz zum beispiel das
natürlich sehr wohl auf dem radar haben
und das unter sehen nochmal zurück
letzter gedanke richard ins hier und
heute
ich habe mich dieser tage mit der
schlange insel beschäftigt das ist ja
diese berühmte insel mit dem mit dem mit
dem [ __ ] [ __ ] you ja und dann wurden die
in die luft gejagt ja dieser ukrainische
posten auf dieser insel wurden
angegriffen haben sie einfach in die
luft gejagt die haben gesagt gebt euch
hieß das nicht später die werden um wie
aufgetaucht diese gefangen oder war das
eine desinformation ich war nie meine
irgendwo hätte ich mal so was gehört
davon dass es immer wieder geschafft
werden kann sogar seine weiche ich will
nicht falsch ich bin nur darauf hinaus
schlange insel ist ein winziger kleine
insel im schwarzen meer nicht weit von
der rumänischen küste und und nicht weit
von der ukrainischen küste und deshalb
sozusagen gehört zur dessau oder zu
morgen zum regierungsbezirk von odessa
24 25 fußballfelder groß
kleiner radius nix so
dasitzen jetzt auch die russen und das
haben die komplette erobert und ist
strategisch von enormer bedeutung
und die frage ist kann man das so zu
sagen so zu lassen weil freiwillig wenn
die das nicht mehr hergeben von von dort
aus hast du quasi direkten zugriff auf
transnistrien und wenn du transnistrien
hast hast du zugriff auf molder und
kannst an verschiedenen ecken wieder
stunk anfangen und kannst vor allen
dingen von transnistrien aus auch wieder
zurück in die ukraine ein unglaublich
zersetzt und und destruktiv
dauerhafter konflikt hier deswegen meine
ich wie wie löst man so was ich meine
das ist doch zum beispiel etwas wo ich
dann immer da dir gut das konkret all
diese gedanken dass ich vielleicht doch
mehr hessischen verhandlungsmasse also
ein bisschen bisschen ist ja vielleicht
wenn die frage ist einfach dürfen wir
das ernsthaft zu lassen oder sind wir
also die frage ist doch wieder was ist
die alternative
alternativ wären ja sagen wir ja immer
mit diesem begriff dürfen also man kann
doch nicht nur wir dürfen noch nicht
etwas und so weit ich verstehe dieses
argument ja es ist völlig legitim aber
wenn uns keine andere wahl bleibt dann
ist es am ende nur noch trotz dass wir
nicht dürfen ja ich frage mich immer
wenn was ist die alternative ist die
alternative wenn wir nicht zu
friedensverhandlungen kommen ja und wenn
diese gebiete nicht
vermutlich also ich weiß nicht ob alles
abgetreten wird oder ob irgendwas
kulturelle auto ich habe kein thema weil
das kleingedruckte weise aber wenn wir
das nicht machen
stoltenberg szenario jahrelanger krieg
ich meine fans nach vier monaten auf
beiden seiten 20 bis 30.000 menschen
befallen sind gestorben sind in der name
in der armee von zivilbevölkerung doch
gar nicht gar nicht geredet was würde
ihnen ein jahrelanger krieg für eine
unendliche menschliche tragödie bedeuten
und wie gut groß müsste der kampfpreis
sein der das werte ich kann das nicht
sehen
naja die das ist halt das was wo man so
daran verzweifeln kann finde ich
man kann schon sibirische tiger mom es
ist jetzt eigentlich sagen ich möchte
das sagen genau wenn das wasser fällst
erfrischt und bin raus kommen zufrieden
wobei es draußen kalt ist ja genau
tatsächlich ja und ich frage mich
manchmal sind wir vielleicht in der
unfassbar
beschissenen situation uns nur so zu
sagen dass wir das ausfechten müssen
weil die konsequenzen ansonsten
katastrophal sein können für denke für
ganz europa ich denke dass so viele
kriege die ewig gedauert haben wie der
vietnamkrieg auch darin bestanden dass
man gesagt hat wir müssen das ausfechten
die amerikaner haben von ihrer
begründung angst vor der domino theorie
gehabt also die domino theorie die
besagt hat wenn wir beim kommunistisch
wird dann wird ein land nach dem anderen
südostasien und so weiter und dann wenn
eins nach dem andern deswegen hat man
gesagt ja das ist natürlich jetzt blutig
und brutal aber wir müssen das müssen
müssen und hier würden im nachhinein
sagen das beste wäre gewesen wenn er gar
nicht erst damit angefangen ja oder
hättet zu einem frühen zeitpunkt also zu
dem zeitpunkt wusste der krieg kann
nicht mehr gewinnen wollen werden das
war die zeit als nächsten präsident
wurden da war klar sonst ist
zurückgetreten hat gesagt wir können den
kriegen nicht mehr gewinnen und nixon
hat den krieg eskalieren lassen obwohl
man ihn nicht mehr gewinnen konnte und
wir würden heute sagen wie viel
menschliches elend drei viertel des
elendes vietnam krieges wurde zu einem
zeitpunkt angerichtet als er kriegt
nicht mehr gewinnen
deswegen markus ich glaube wir müssen
nicht
die frage wird uns noch länger
beschäftigen wird
auf jeden fall sammer für unsere
generation auch für unsere kinder und so
weiter ist das ist glaube ich sozusagen
die große frage an der sich ganz viel
das entscheidet und da werden wir
wahrscheinlich noch lange nicht es
kleider hängen also ich habe die
hoffnung ja also ich auch nur jeder hat
ja seine seine wurst hoffnung ich habe
meine meine hoffnung dass der krieg
vielleicht tatsächlich nur noch wenige
monate dauert dass es keinen frieden
gibt aber ein waffenstillstand dass sich
dieser friedensprozess unendlich
hinziehen wird und ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass es irgendwann nicht mehr
diese wichtigkeit und diese relevanz hat
und meine große hoffnung ist dass die
menschheit erkennen dass ihr
hauptproblem so grausig dass es eben
nicht der krieg in der ukraine ist
sondern der krieg darum dass wir in 50
60 jahren noch eine bewohnbare erde vor
sinn denn das ist ja das ärgerliche an
diesem ganzen mist bei jedem in die luft
fliegen fliegenden tanklager von all den
milliarden die da für waffen ausgegeben
werden und so was ja dass ich immer
denke wie kann die menschheit in einer
solchen situation wo sie eigentlich um
den fortbestand ihrer existenz kämpft
sich dann noch in so einen dreckigen
scheiß da verwickeln der dem verlieren
wir gedacht haben ja den brauchen wir
nun wirklich nicht mehr sind aber alles
fragen die wir niemals den ukrainern
stellen mussten sondern alle nur putin
ja aber selbst wenn wir putin von ihnen
keine antwort kriegen ja ich weiß du
wirst ihn nicht als als gast in einer
sendung kriegen
können wer drauf aber wie er ist auch
völlig unerheblich nur
in diesen krieg begonnen genau datieren
der neben der nicht verhandeln will und
er jetzt schon wieder an was auch nicht
verhandeln bildhauen der jetzt schon
wieder anfang der treibt ihn treibt in
den kriegs hoch was ist aber verhandeln
will weil die der muss verhandeln wolle
er wusste wollen weil sie die andere
konsequenz wäre die ganze ukraine zu
erobern und was das alles mit sich
bringt ja daran führt er sich verheben
und deswegen wird er wenn er seinen
zwischen kriegsziel erreicht hat also
dann jetzt und johannsen mit sicherheit
fahren wenn ich gespannt ich bin sicher
dass er verhandelt nur ich bin noch
ziemlich sicher dass die vorstellungen
die wir haben muss man immer sagen wir
es wieder also dass die interessen des
westens interessen der ukraine sind auch
nicht ganz identisch sind nicht
identisch da ich glaube das ist ewig
keinen frieden gibt aber hoffentlich bei
den waffen schlüssel sprecher tanke dpa
unser erster video-podcast war ist warm
geworden hier drin waren ein guter
austausch fand ich konstruktiv viele
neue gedanken und
bis zum nächsten mal vielen dank
[Musik]
eine produktion von m 52 und posters bei
homer im auftrag des zdf
[Musik]